this morning on the dish North Carolina
born chef Sam Talbot he had to learn
about food at an early age not for
pleasure but for health at 12 he was
diagnosed with type 1 diabetes helping
others deal with the condition has been
a lifelong passion he recently opened
pretty southern in Brooklyn New York a
casual eatery that includes healthy
alternatives to traditional southern
dishes and earlier this year he
published 100% real his second cookbook
chef Sam Talbot good morning and welcome
to the dish thank you so much for having
me it's so lovely to see you guys what
are the dishes we're looking at here
everything you want is what we're
looking at here fried chicken right
there
Center right you know it so little bit
of fried chicken with some honey
drizzled on top Carolina's favorite we
have blackened shrimp pimento mac and
cheese buttermilk biscuits yeah as you
know why you can't start a meal like
this that buttermilk biscuits we have
sweet potato waffles little baked ham
cranberry chutney and then also spiked
Arnold Palmer the little lemon lemonade
and iced tea so okay so this is the
perfect follow up to my very heavy
Thanksgiving meal just two days ago but
when we talk about Southern cuisine we
often don't think lighter how are you
making it lighter and healthier we'll
see that's the thing right at being
diagnosed with diabetes at a really
young age I knew that food matters
everything we put into our body food
matters but I also know that food from
the low country happens to be one of the
best cuisines on the planet yeah maybe
I'm biased but it's also maybe not the
healthiest
you need to do things normally so but
the flavor intact well that's easy you
know normally where things are using a
lot of dairy if you're using heavy cream
or butter we substitute hemp milk or
almond milk or coconut oil so if you're
talking about something like macaroni
and cheese that's normally made with a
lot of heavy cream but you do it with
butternut squash and coconut milk Wow
right like what a difference things can
make if you're normally making fried
chicken in just canola oil well if you
you know if you change that the oil you
fried and grapeseed oil maybe you brine
it and vinegar to speed up the cooking
process everything changes yeah okay so
how did you get into this we know that
grandma
there's played a role in your early
color you always do you know they write
grandmother's are the best and you know
you grow up thinking your grandparents
are just like the sweetest the coolest
and so you know growing up my
grandmother we lived at the kind of like
the end our street ran into a farmers
market where my smaller one though you
know it was just fresh eggs
you know people made sausage dairy milk
and we would go back to the house and
literally just do like scrambled eggs
but like proper slow scrambled eggs not
like the ones with the brown edges so I
really fell in love at a young age
cooking with my grandmother my mom in
the kitchen and then it just turned into
this full-blown love affair I just you
know I was cooking and getting fired
from jobs
the spiked on our partners 14 and no and
then I started working at Dean & Deluca
and that's when four oh wow my
grandmother like you know just the with
the comfort and love in the kitchen then
going into professional kitchen like
Dean & Deluca and having people that
this is their careers right now 16 I
didn't know right right so so pretty
southern this is the kind of food that
you could put in a very large dining
room and keep the people coming in but
you've got very intimate dining room at
pretty southern why the tight confines
you know I think kind of the way of the
world today people it's it's a fast
casual world you know people don't
necessarily don't want to be sitting in
a restaurant for three hours right we
have our lives you want to get out you
want to be active you want to be with
your family for me I love being outdoors
you know and I just like being outside
being across from a carrot power I want
to be out there so the restaurant is
really it's built to come in have
delicious food but you can take it to go
you can you can bring a picnic to the
park it's it's a great little flow it's
a great location it's a great
neighborhood yeah it couldn't be more
pleased it's great great great all
around and we love Brooklyn chef as I
asked you to she's not sign this dish
that's a custom on this program awesome
if you could share this bounty with
anybody past or present who would it be
pastor present so I would have to say my
grandfather because I never really got a
chance father oh yeah grandfather never
really got a chance to cook for my
grandfather in the way that you know I'm
when you're 17 you don't really know how
to cook I'm 39
did I say that I'm twenty-two right now
yes and no I would love to you
my grandfather and just have him like
really see what I become and you know
proud of my buttermilk biscuits I know
we're proud of them they know he's
doubly yes Sam Talbot thank you and for
more on Chef Talbot and the dish head to
our website at CBS this morning calm